Welcome to Smartless, please hold.
Welcome to Smartless.
Can I help you?
Hello?
Hello? Hello?
欢迎来到 Smartless，请稍候。欢迎来到 Smartless，请稍候。欢迎来到 Smartless，请稍候。欢迎来到 Smartless，请稍候。欢迎来到 Smartless。有什么需要我帮忙的吗？喂？喂？喂？
Hello?
Welcome to Smartless.
Speed.
Mark.
Jason, where are you right now?
It's Sunday.
The camera, Mark.
喂？喂？欢迎来到 Smartless。速度。马克。杰森，你现在在哪儿？今天是星期天。镜头，马克。
Oh, God, he's got the lingo.
It's still, like, because he does it, you do it.
You're still doing it 15 hours a day.
Sorry, second sticks.
Second sticks on B.
This guy never quits.
He loves the lingo.
Willie, how did you play?
哦，天哪，他满嘴行业黑话。这还是老样子，因为他这么干，所以你也这么干。你每天还是花15个小时干这个。抱歉，B组镜头换了新卡。B组的镜头换了新卡。这家伙从不收手。他太喜欢这些行话了。威利，你打得怎么样？
I played okay.
Played, yeah, played okay.
Didn't get a full nine in even because we were doing this.
I left Abe out there.
Oh, you did?
Yeah, I mean, it's all good.
All good.
Is it as good as the gum?
我打得还行。打得，对，打得还行。甚至都没打满九个洞，因为我们在忙这个。我把阿布留在那儿了。哦，是吗？对，我是说，都挺好的。都挺好的。有口香糖那么好吗？
I was just going to say, can you...
What?
Go ahead, Sean, yeah, and...
I was just...
And can you turn your gum down.
Yeah.
有口香糖那么好吗？我正要说，你能……什么？说吧，肖恩，对，还有……我只是……还有你能把口香糖的声音小点吗？好吧。好吧。
You want to know something,
crazy yeah okay ready so yeah last week maybe and jb you you you you uh forwarded shana and both shan
and me this the thing about um from a couple episodes ago where you asked me if i ever pooped in front
of amy oh yeah page six picked it up on this real slow news day yeah everybody loves a good poop
story i guess and they're like and then like some of the headlines were ridiculous right just
Like trying to like imply that you shut me down and you're upset and I got too personal and too gross.
Dude, so then Lewis K., my trustee publicist, gets an email or a message from somebody at one of the rags wanting to know if you want to comment, right?
No, even better.
你想听个事吗，疯狂的，好，准备好了，所以，对，上周某个时候，然后杰博，你，你，你，你，呃，转发了肖娜还有肖恩和我，就是关于那个……从前几集的节目开始的，当时你问我有没有在艾米面前拉过大便，哦，对，第六版（Page Six）在新闻比较清淡的时候报道了这个，对，我想大家都喜欢听关于大便的好故事，然后他们就……然后有些标题太离谱了，对吧？就像是故意暗示你把我压下去了，你很不高兴，然后我变得太私人、太恶心了。老兄，然后刘易斯·K，我信任的公关人员，收到了一封邮件，或者说来自某个八卦小报某人的消息，想知道你想不想回应，对吧？不，甚至更好。
No.
I won't, who, one of the rags who will remain the National Enquirer.
And they said, left a message asking.
Are they still around?
They're going to run a story that they've heard in light of this story about,
about the poop thing, that they've heard
that there's a long-standing riff
between you and me, J.B.,
不。我不会，谁，其中一家八卦小报——姑且称之为《国家询问报》（National Enquirer）。他们说，留了言询问。他们还在吗？他们打算发表一篇报道，说他们听说鉴于这个关于那个大便的事情的报道，听说你和我之间，杰博，
that has never come to the surface.
And would we like to comment on it?
And Lewis and I laughed for five minutes straight.
And that there's aliens.
There's aliens, too.
He's circling...
No, but just so that people can understand
how absurd this stuff is.
一直存在着一种从未浮出水面的长期不和，我们对此有什么想回应的吗？我和刘易斯笑了整整五分钟。还有外星人。还有外星人。他在打转……不，但这只是为了让人们明白这些东西有多荒谬。
I know.
I hope that they literally, out of whole cloth,
whatever, make it up.
I know, but I hope people...
No, who cares, me?
find enjoyment and pleasure and kind of fun from rags and tabloids and things like that.
Because I guess it is, you know, like the print media is struggling and they all need all forms
我知道。我希望他们真的是凭空捏造，随便怎么都行，把它们编出来。我知道，但我希望人们……不，谁在乎呢，我吗？我知道，但我希望人们……从八卦小报和类似的东西中找到乐趣、快乐和某种好玩的感觉。因为我想，你知道的，比如印刷媒体现在很艰难，它们都需要各种形式的
of it to be kind of up and robust, I suppose. And so I don't wish, you know, the demise of any
form of media, but, you know, I just hope people like read it right and kind of like get a smile
while they're checking out their groceries and, you know, like, oh, look at that. That's probably
not true. But boy, that's a fun headline.
Yeah, I mean, it was so funny to see out of the blue.
I think in the world we live in, though, that's a good point, Jason Bateman, where I think with the lying and you know who to trust and which side to, I think people now look at headlines differently.
I would hope so.
I do.
内容保持活跃和强劲，我想是这样的。所以我不希望，你知道的，任何形式的媒体消亡，但是，你知道的，我只希望人们能正确阅读，然后在结账时看一眼，能会心一笑，你知道的，比如，哦，看那个。那可能不是真的。但天哪，这标题真有意思。对，我是说，突然看到这个觉得太搞笑了。不过我觉得在我们生活的这个世界里，这是一个很好的观点，杰森·巴特曼，我觉得现在有了谎言，你知道该信任谁，该站在哪一边，我觉得人们现在看待新闻标题的方式不同了。我希望如此。我是这么觉得的。
From 10 years ago, I'll look at something and be like, oh, I bet you I need to hear the other side of that.
Yeah.
You know?
Oh, so we're going to get right to you, surprise guest.
We've had a lot of chiving in from the surprise guests.
Not even on Chinese.
Fuck.
Sean,
从10年前开始，我看到某些事情会觉得，哦，我敢打赌我得听听这件事的另一面。对。你知道吗？哦，所以我们要直接邀请你上场了，惊喜嘉宾。我们收到了很多关于惊喜嘉宾的爆料。甚至都不是中文的。操。肖恩，
lose your dog, Sean.
Well, you guys are going to love our guests today.
Let's get her in here.
I know.
She's already here.
She's very exciting for me and for you guys, it's going to be great.
She is the seventh of ten children raised in a Hasidic household in Montreal.
把你的狗管好，肖恩。好吧，你们今天一定会喜欢我们的嘉宾。让她进来吧。我知道。她已经在这儿了。我知道。她对我来说非常令人兴奋，对你们来说也会很棒。她是蒙特利尔一个哈西德派家庭养育的十个孩子中的老七。
Where money was tight.
Her mother took the kids to the library and weekends.
Hasidic household in Montreal.
Yeah.
You know my joke.
When I meet a Hasidic Jew, I was when to meet the other side, the Alkaline Jews.
Thanks.
Oh, so waiting on the jokes.
当时家里很拮据。她的母亲周末会带孩子们去图书馆。蒙特利尔的哈西德派家庭。对。你知道我的笑话。当我遇到一个哈西德犹太人时，我总是想遇到另一面，那些碱性犹太人。谢谢。哦，真会抖包袱。
She studied accounting and started doing stand-up
while she was still in college.
Later, she posed as a courier to hand-deliver her spec script
to the president of HBO Canada.
She went on to win an Emmy for her writing
and then John Mullaney directed her Netflix special
calling her one of the funniest people living,
I agree wholeheartedly, self-described as a 73-year-old man.
她学的是会计，还在上大学时就开始做单口喜剧。后来，她假装成信使，亲自把自己的剧本样稿送到加拿大 HBO 总裁手里。她后来凭剧本获得了艾美奖，接着约翰·木兰尼（John Mulaney）导演了她的 Netflix 特辑，称她是活着的最好笑的人之一，我完全赞同，她自称是一个73岁的老头。
It's the truly hilarious Robbie Hoffman.
No.
Hey, Robbie Hoffman.
Look at this.
There's no way the fellas know me.
Robbie, first of all, Robbie, you know I know you because we've met, A.
Fine, fine.
And you worked on that kid's show.
这就是真正搞笑的罗比·霍夫曼。不。嘿，罗比·霍夫曼。瞧瞧。这帮家伙不可能认识我。罗比，首先，罗比，你知道我认识你，因为我们见过面，行吧，行吧。而且你还参与了那个儿童节目的制作。
Robbie, we had dinner and I think you blacked out well before dessert got there, so I doubt you remember it.
Oh, yeah, that sounds like me.
And you don't think I would remember if I had dinner with the guy from Switch.
Hey, huh?
You don't think my whole family?
When I tell you, my family watched Switch, like people live.
watch like the hangover movie or something. It's like, my mother.
That's not a family movie. That's about a guy swapping goo. We love the movie. My mother's like,
罗比，我们吃过饭，而且我想你在甜点端上来之前就已经喝断片了，所以我怀疑你还记得。哦，对，这听起来确实像我。而且你觉得如果我和《交换身家》里的那个家伙一起吃过饭，我会不记得吗？哦，哈？你觉得我全家会不记得吗？我跟你说，我全家人看《交换身家》就像人们看《宿醉》那样的电影一样。就像，我妈。那可不是什么家庭电影。那讲的是一个家伙换体液的故事。我们很喜欢这部电影。我妈就会说，
why don't we rent Switch again? You kids love that. Jason, don't talk her out of it. They liked it.
They enjoyed it. We love Switch. It was originally called the Baster. Okay? Did you know that?
Starring Jason Baster. Yeah. Well, the little kid, I don't know if he was ethnically Jewish or whatever,
but he said something that we related to, but he said,
Your character explains him what a hypochondria is.
And he goes, I think I have that.
Yeah.
And that was like literally like I was seen.
我们为什么不再租一遍《交换身家》？你们这些小孩子喜欢那个。杰森，别劝她放弃。他们喜欢。他们很享受。我们超爱《交换身家》。它原本叫《捐精者》（The Baster）。好吗？你知道吗？由杰森·巴斯特主演。对。那个小男孩，我不知道他是不是有犹太血统还是怎么的，但他说了一些我们很有共鸣的话，他说，你的角色向他解释了什么是恐病症。他说，我觉得我有这个。对。这就好像我literally被看见了。
I'm like, oh, my God.
I know.
It was, anyway, you're amazing in every movie.
And also, Jennifer Aniston, and we can cut whatever.
Does she know she's a lesbian icon?
She might not know.
Is that true?
我就想，哦，天哪。我知道。我知道。不管怎样，你在每部电影里都太棒了。还有，詹妮弗·安妮斯顿，我们可以剪掉任何部分。她知道自己是女同性恋偶像吗？她可能不知道。是这样吗？
I think she's an icon to everybody.
She is, but she's specifically, Sean,
and it's not this not all men thing that you need to get into off the top here, okay?
Right, okay.
Yes, everybody loves her.
Can I gloat for a second on a similar subject?
There was a moment there, and I think the boys know this,
so I apologize if you've heard it before,
我觉得她是所有人的偶像。她是，但她特别地，肖恩，这不是那种你需要一开始就介入的“不是所有男人”的话题，好吧？好吧，好吧。是的，大家都喜欢她。我能就类似的主题幸灾乐祸一会儿吗？当时有那么一会儿，我想小伙子们也知道这点，所以如果你们听过了，我先道个歉，
that I thought that I was qualified as a gay icon
when I found out from my attorney one day on a startling phone call
that Jason Bateman.com was a gay porn hub site.
This is right.
Gay porn hub website.
So from Jason Bateman.com, you could go to hundreds of gay porn sites.
So I was like...
Stop selling us.
有一天我从律师那里接到一个令人震惊的电话，我以为自己有资格成为一个同性恋偶像，因为我发现 JasonBateman.com 是一个同性恋色情网站。这话说得对。同性恋色情网站。所以通过 JasonBateman.com，你可以进入几百个同性恋色情网站。所以我当时就……别再推销我们了。
It's J-A-S-O-N.
But yes, so I was flattered for a flash there
that I was like, oh, well, they could have picked any name.
By the way, I think you're a gay icon,
but we know mostly men of a lot of gay icons.
We know the share, we know Barbara Streisand,
we know Jason Bateman.
Nobody knows what the dykes are looking at.
是 J-A-S-O-N。不过是的，所以在那一瞬间我还挺受宠若惊的，我想，哦，好吧，他们本来可以随便挑个名字的。顺便说一句，我觉得你是同性恋偶像，但我们知道很多同性恋偶像大多是男性。我们知道雪儿（Cher），我们知道芭芭拉·史翠珊（Barbra Streisand），我们知道杰森·巴特曼。没人知道拉拉们在看什么。
Right?
Right.
I'm sure.
And Jennifer, we don't have that men.
It's like, what are we looking at?
Jennifer Anderson, it's all because she wore a belt in the 90s.
By the way, her credit.
But, you know, we don't need much, but you have a belt on,
对吧？对吧。我确信。还有詹妮弗，我们没那么多男性粉丝。就像，我们在看什么？詹妮弗·安妮斯顿，这全是因为她在90年代系了一条皮带。顺便说一句，她的功劳。但是，你知道，我们不需要太多，但你系了一条皮带，
and we're doing, like, nobody's really thinking of us.
So, not that she even wants to be.
One of the poorest communities that could be in you.
It's not like gay men, they go out, they buy tickets,
they're going to go see Lady Gaga, like,
Dykes are home with the cats.
Like, you don't make money off of us.
But we respect you.
然后我们就在那儿，其实没人真的在想我们。所以，倒不是她自己想当。这可以说是你身处的最贫穷的社群之一。不像同性恋男士，他们会出门，买票，去看Lady Gaga，而拉拉们则和猫呆在家里。所以你从我们身上赚不到钱。但我们尊重你。
And that's it.
That's it.
By the way, might I add, Robbie,
that you and I are dressed exactly the same today.
Are we?
Is this a gay thing?
Glasses, baseball hat.
I got a hoodie on, too.
就是这样。就是这样。顺便说一句，我能补充一下吗，罗比，你和我今天穿得一模一样。是吗？这是同性恋风格吗？眼镜，棒球帽。我还穿着连帽衫呢。
I was saying, wait, let me be gay.
Sean dresses like a college dude from 1998.
Wait, Robbie, I didn't know you were from Montreal.
I had no idea.
Well, I'm originally from New York,
and then I grew up in Montreal.
So you got the bio right.
And both are true.
我刚想说，等一下，让我来表现得很同性恋。肖恩穿得就像个1998年的大学男生。等等，罗比，我不知道你是蒙特利尔人。我完全不知道。嗯，我原本来自纽约，然后我在蒙特利尔长大。所以你的个人资料没弄错。这两点都是真的。
How about that?
What got things up to Montreal?
My mother is from Montreal.
So it's not...
My mother had 10 kids,
joined the Hasidicult, had 10 kids.
I'm the 7th of that.
怎么样？怎么样？是什么让你去了蒙特利尔？我妈妈是蒙特利尔人。所以这不是……我妈妈生了10个孩子，加入了哈西德派，生了10个孩子。我是其中的老七。
What got her kicked out of Williamsburg?
We were in Crown Heights.
All right.
Yeah.
And...
Not even a giggle.
No.
是什么把她从威廉斯堡赶出来的？我们住在皇冠高地（Crown Heights）。好吧。对。而且……连个咯咯笑声都没有。不。不。
I'll work harder.
Now, Robbie, where...
Where are you right?
No, are you on tour?
No, I'm in my office slash gym.
I got this type of, it's lats.
The pull down, yeah.
But I don't have any weights on the lats.
我会更努力的。现在，罗比，你在……你现在在哪？不对，你在巡演吗？不，我在我的办公室兼健身房。我有这种，是练背肌的。下拉训练，对。但我背肌的杠铃上没有加任何重量。
My friend Dan is supposed to come over, Dan Dan down here.
If you listen to this pod, I don't know what weights this needs.
He put this together and then he just, there's no weights on it.
What about some?
Some would be good.
No, no, we need some sort of a stack.
It's a specific...
Are you East Coast?
我的朋友丹本来要过来的，就是下面这个丹。如果你听这个播客的话，我不知道这需要什么重量。他把它装好了，然后就，上面根本没有重量。加点重量怎么样？加点重量会挺好的。不，不，我们需要某种配重片。这是一个特定的……你是东海岸的吗？
Mr. West Coast.
I live in Los Angeles.
Oh, you do.
Okay.
All right, all right.
How do you like Los Angeles?
I like it a lot.
I mean, you know, L.A's a dump.
西海岸先生。我住在洛杉矶。哦，你住在那里。好吧。好吧，好吧。你觉得洛杉矶怎么样？我挺喜欢的。我是说，你知道的，洛杉矶是个垃圾堆。
New York's a shithole, but there's nowhere else to live, really.
Yeah.
What about Montreal?
No, no.
It's freezing and there's nothing doing that.
Why do you get out of there in the winter?
I'm just not going, Jason.
All right, all right.
纽约是个大粪坑，但真的没别的地方可住了。对。蒙特利尔呢？不，不。那里冷得要命，而且什么都没有。你冬天怎么不在那儿待着？我就是不去，杰森。好吧，好吧。
Stop pushing me.
Now, now I, you said, I love that you're a self-disclose,
subscribe 73-year-old man because I am kind of too.
By the way, your special is so fucking funny.
Robbie, you're so funny.
It's unreal.
I'm sold already.
In 10 minutes, I'm sold.
别再逼我了。现在，现在我，你刚才说，我很喜欢你自称是73岁的老头，因为其实我也是那种人。顺便说一句，你的特辑太他妈搞笑了。罗比，你太搞笑了。简直难以置信。我已经粉了。短短10分钟，我就被圈粉了。
Yeah.
Where do you get your fearlessness from for
all the stuff you talk about?
Your rant, which I would never go on about,
about they, them.
Yeah.
Is really funny.
But I don't think I'm fearless.
对。你那些你谈论的所有事情的无畏精神是从哪里来的？你的长篇大论——关于“他们/他他们”（they/them），我绝不会去谈论这个——真的很好笑。但我并不觉得自己无畏。
I think I'm extremely afraid all of the time.
Like the difference is,
like I'm simultaneously extremely afraid and extremely confident.
And I don't know why that is, but it's not like I say all these things or whatever.
It's I'm thinking them, right?
So it's not like I want to think them.
It's like I have a joke about pedophilia.
I wish I never knew what it was.
我觉得自己无时无刻不在感到极度的恐惧。区别在于，我同时感到极度的恐惧和极度的自信。我不知道这是为什么，但这并不是说我把这些都说出来什么的。我只是在脑子里想，对吧？所以并不是我故意想去想这些。比如我有一个关于恋童癖的笑话。我真希望我从来不知道那是什么。
Right, right, okay.
I wish I never knew what it was.
But now that I do, I have a thought about it.
I didn't choose this thought.
Sure.
I didn't.
So I'm telling you, but I am extremely afraid.
We can all agree that the subject is a horrible thing,
对，对，好吧。我真希望我从来不知道那是什么。但既然我知道了，我对它就有了想法。这不是我主动选择的想法。当然。我没有。所以我才告诉你，但我确实感到极度恐惧。我们都可以同意这个主题是一件可怕的事，
but the way you talk about it,
I have questions.
I have funny questions.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have questions.
And, you know, so it's not that I'm fearless.
I think I, like, wake up afraid.
但你谈论它的方式，我有疑问。我有疑问。我有很好笑的疑问。对，对，对。我有疑问。所以，并不是说我无畏。我想我大概是带着恐惧醒来的。
I'm always a little anxious.
But just because I'm afraid doesn't mean I don't get to do something.
It's kind of like I was afraid my whole life taking the bus, you know, the last bus home or something.
You know, always looking, always looking.
But I still have to get on a bus.
Right, right.
If I don't get on this bus, fuck, I'm going out.
I got to wait for the first bus, five in the morning.
我总是有点焦虑。但仅仅因为我害怕并不意味着我就不能去做某些事。这有点像我一辈子都害怕坐公交车，你知道的，坐最后一班车回家什么的。你知道，总是东张西望，总是提心吊胆。但我还是得坐公交车。对，对。如果我不坐这辆车，操，我就出不去了。我得等第一班车，早上五点。
So, you know, it's just because I'm afraid, that's probably what comes from.
I've been afraid my whole life, but I still have to do.
So you want to attack those things because it scares you, and after you've attacked them,
or not just an attack, I'm just saying, like, approach them or speak about them or joke about them,
it probably is fulfilling in some way.
I don't want to.
I wish I never had to do any of this.
Sure.
所以，你知道，仅仅因为我害怕，这可能就是原因所在。我一辈子都在害怕，但我还是得去做。所以你想去攻击那些事情是因为它让你感到害怕，而在你攻击了它们之后，或者不仅仅是攻击，我的意思是，接近它们、谈论它们或拿它们开玩笑，它可能在某种程度上是一种满足？我不想。我真希望我永远不必做这些。当然。
I feel...
What would you rather be doing?
Nothing.
I'd love to do nothing.
When did you first realize that by joking about something became a little less scary?
It's always scary.
I just live in fear.
Right, right.
我觉得……你宁愿做什么？什么都不做。我非常乐意什么都不做。你什么时候第一次意识到，通过拿某事开玩笑，它会变得不那么可怕了？一直都很可怕。我只是生活在恐惧中。对，对。
But when did it start?
Like, as a little kid, was there like joking around the house?
Well, you grew up very religious, right?
You mentioned that in the open.
And then you mentioned about your mom.
Like, you grew up very, very religious.
I bet having a sense of humor about it, as Jason's saying,
when you first have those first inclinations of thoughts,
但这一切是什么时候开始的？比如作为一个小孩子，家里是不是经常开玩笑？嗯，你在非常虔诚的环境中长大，对吧？你在开场时提到了这一点。然后你提到了你妈妈。就像，你在非常、非常虔诚的环境中长大。我敢打赌，对它有一种幽默感，正如杰森所说，当你第一次萌生那些想法时，
that go against what you're involved
and that must have been scary.
Well, here's the thing.
It's like nothing was off limits.
My whole family is funny.
My whole community is funny.
I come from a funny people.
Right.
那些违背你所处环境的想法，那一定很可怕。嗯，情况是这样的。就像没有什么是不可以开玩笑的。我们全家都很搞笑。我们整个社区都很搞笑。我来自一个幽默的民族。对。
And it's just, it's brutal and funny
at the same time, always.
Yeah.
So it could be, you know,
it's never too soon.
We didn't have these types of concepts.
That's when I got into, you know,
more normal white or rich spaces
而且它总是既残酷又搞笑。对。所以，你知道的，永远不会嫌太早。我们没有这些类型的新概念。那是当我进入到，你知道的，更正常的白人或富裕空间时
where they had this idea
too soon, to this, to that,
to the other.
other, we didn't have, really, if it was funny, if you threw it.
If you bombed, your brother, you know, shut up, what the fuck?
Right, right.
You were told on the spot.
Yeah.
他们才有这种不能太早、这个不能说、那个不能说的观念，我们真的没有，只要好笑，如果你扔出一个梗。如果你搞砸了，你哥哥就会说，闭嘴，他妈的说什么呢？对，对。当场就会被指出来。对。
Well, with 10 kids.
It was immediate all of the time.
And you're saying that's cultural.
That wasn't unique to your family.
No, it was cultural.
And, yeah, we had a million cylinders flying all the time.
Some people were crying.
Some people were laughing.
好吧，家里有十个孩子。这种互动是一直都在发生的。你刚才说那是文化使然。那不是你家的特例？不，这是文化。而且，是的，我们有无数个齿轮一直在高速运转。有人在哭。有人在笑。
It was always together.
there was not ever neat lines.
There was never a time and a place.
Like these types of concepts of,
well, it's not after time or it's too soon.
That language didn't even enter.
What was the big comedic influence in the house?
Was there a particular comic that you guys like to all watch
总是聚在一起。从来没有什么清晰的界限。从来没有什么时间地点的讲究。比如什么“时机不对”或者“为时尚早”之类的大道理。这种语言甚至都不会出现。家里最大的喜剧影响是什么？有没有哪个特定的喜剧演员是你们大家都很喜欢看的
or movies or something like that?
We didn't really do that, but my mother was very funny.
Yeah.
We liked laughing at her, mostly.
My father was funny objectively,
like just jokes and stuff.
you know, saying, you know, I shower once a week
whether I need to or not,
或者电影之类的内容？我们其实不怎么看那些，但我妈妈非常搞笑。对。我们主要喜欢嘲笑她。我父亲客观上也很搞笑，就是讲讲笑话什么的，
or things like that.
But the whole family is funny,
but the whole family was also brutal.
It was, you know, I grew up, you know, everybody,
we grew up poor and my brothers were fighting
and there was a lot of physical abuse
and toppling over each other.
And I have five brothers
你知道的，比如说什么，我一周洗一次澡，不管需不需要，诸如此类的话。但全家人都很搞笑，不过全家人也都很残酷。那是，你知道的，我是在，你知道的，大家都，我们家里很穷，我哥哥们打架，有大量的肢体虐待和互相推搡。我有五个兄弟，
and my mother couldn't pull my brothers apart.
But there was also laughing.
Like, I don't know.
It was all together all the time.
So it doesn't mean I'm not.
Are you the only girl?
No, I have four sisters, too.
Oh, ten total.
我妈妈根本拉不开我哥哥们。但也有欢笑。总之，我不知道。所有这些总是混杂在一起。所以这并不意味着我不是……你是唯一的女孩吗？不，我还有四个姐妹。哦，总共十个。
Do the math.
You're ten total.
You have five brothers.
What are you doing?
I didn't hold on to the top of the interview.
Why are you?
What were you doing?
自己算算。自己算算。你们总共十个。你有五个兄弟。你在干什么？我刚才在采访开始时没抓稳。你在干什么？你刚才在干什么？
It's a lot, Jason.
I feel for you.
It's a lot.
He's still, he's still.
And when you're that pretty a face, you don't have to do so much.
Yeah.
He doesn't have to listen.
If he dips in, he dips in.
这可真不少，杰森。我为你感到难过。这挺多的。他还在，他还在。当你的脸长得那么好看时，你就不需要做太多了。对。他不需要听。如果他想插话，他就插话。
I have to catch everything.
I got to be on it.
But if you're Jason Bateman, you catch this,
you catch that.
It's like.
It's been an easy ride since they won it if you're Jason Baby.
Hey, let's- Very soft.
He's a sex.
我必须抓住所有东西。我得时刻保持专注。但如果你是杰森·巴特曼，你抓得住这个，抓得住那个。这就好像。自从他们赢了之后，日子就一直挺轻松的，如果你是杰森·巴比的话。嘿，让我们——非常温和。他是个性感符号。
He's a gay sex symbol.
Who cares?
I'm a fucking icon.
Hang on, a gay icon.
Wait, so I thought I was a gay icon, to be honest, because I played a couple gay characters.
It's Lady Gaga, Barbara Streisand, and Bateman.
Wow.
I'm out.
他是个同性恋性感符号。谁在乎呢？我他妈是个偶像。等等，一个同性恋偶像。等等，老实说，我以为我是一个同性恋偶像，因为我演过几个同性恋角色。那是Lady Gaga、芭芭拉·史翠珊和巴特曼。哇。我出局了。
Hey, Robbie, are you still close to your family?
Yes.
Yeah, great.
That's some nice.
Yes, we're like the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
but Jewish and poor.
Right.
A lot of us are very close.
嘿，罗比，你现在还和你的家人很亲密吗？是的。对，太好了。真是不错。是的，我们就像……像犹太人一样，但很穷。对。我们很多人关系都非常紧密。
Well, I love, so, so,
I won't ask you to say jokes again,
but I, but as a fan,
I have to repeat some of them
because they're funny.
And so when you said
having money for the first time
he would go over somebody's,
嗯，我喜欢，所以，所以，我不会要求你再讲笑话，但作为粉丝，我不得不重复其中一些，因为它们太好笑了。所以当你说第一次有钱时，他会去某个人的家里，
this is so funny.
You went over to somebody's...
No, she didn't have to say it wrong
and then she's going to correct you.
And he can, you know what?
Smart strategy.
Yeah, that's okay.
Sean, by your impression,
这太好玩了。你去了某个人的……不，她不用说错，然后她会纠正你。而且他可以，你知道吗？聪明的策略。对，没关系。肖恩，凭你的印象，
do your impression of Robbie.
Sean, do your impression of Robbie.
Robbie, he does a great impression.
of you all the time. Do the whole thing.
Do it. Yeah, so I went over to this guys
you know, these people's house and I was like
no, um, when you first
The anti-Semitism at 9.50
模仿一下罗比。肖恩，模仿一下罗比。罗比，他一直在模仿你，模仿得可棒了。把整段都演出来。演吧。对，所以我就去了这个家伙的家，你知道的，这些人的家，然后我说，不，嗯，当你第一次……上午9:50的反犹太主义是这样的，不知道。我想，我来到这里。我昨晚还在工作。他们说早上9点。她利用休息时间在周日早上9点赶来。她在奉献自己的时间。肖恩，你得来一段这种老套的、他妈的，你在干什么，
a.m. is this don't know.
I'm like,
I come in here. I work last night.
They said 9 a.m.
She comes in here on her, on her time off on a Sunday,
9.m. She's giving her time.
And Sean, you got to do this
cliche, fucking, what are you doing,
老兄？有那么多工作。然后我还得听这些反犹……继续吧，肖恩。肖恩，先来一声“哎哟”，你个混蛋。对，开始吧。真的。不，你，天哪，我忘了我刚才说什么了。
dude? There's so much work.
And then I got to hear this anti's
Go on, Sean.
Sean, start with an oie, you dick.
Yeah, here we go.
Literally.
No, that you,
God, I forgot what I was I said.
哦，对了。就是你，当你开始和那些有钱人混在一起时，因为你出身，我出身的背景和你非常相似。大家庭，非常穷，挤在一起，没有父母管教。爱尔兰天主教徒？我喜欢爱尔兰天主教徒。对，都一样。我们都有过同样的破事。
Oh, yeah.
That you, when you first started being around richer people with money,
because you come, I come from a very similar background than you.
Big family, very poor, on top of each other, no parenting.
Irish Catholic?
I love Irish Catholic.
Yeah, it's the same.
We all have the same shit.
但不管怎样，你去了某个人的家里去游泳，他们有毛巾，这让你大开眼界。你知道那是谁的家吗？谁的？那是西尔弗曼的家。谁是西尔弗曼？萨拉·西尔弗曼（Sarah Silverman）。
But anyway, you went over to a person's house to go swimming,
and they had towels.
and that was mind-blowing to you.
You know who's house that was?
Whose?
It was Silverman's house.
Who's Silverman?
Sarah Silverman.
哦，哇。真搞笑。所以我离开她，是因为我总是给萨拉·西尔弗曼找麻烦，因为很明显我是她的终身粉丝，然后我很喜欢杰瑞·宋飞（Jerry Seinfeld）的《杰瑞·宋飞路演喜剧》（Comedians in Cars Getting Coffee），当他开车去接她时，他是在一辆车里，他去一个公寓接她。而我想，我很穷，我他妈的，你知道的，就像，我想，她居然住在公寓里？
Oh, wow.
That's funny.
So I left her, because I always give Sarah Silverman a hard time because obviously I'm a
lifelong fan, and then I love Jerry Seinfeld's comedians and cars getting coffee,
and when he picks her up in a car, he picks her up at an apartment.
And I'm going, I'm poor, I'm fucking, you know, like, I'm like, she lives in an apartment.
apartment? Like, I was horrified. I'm like, what's even the point of dreaming if you're Sarah Silverman?
And you couldn't even get out. She's in the fucking apartment, he picks her up. So I, when Sarah
公寓？就像，我被震惊了。我在想，如果你是萨拉·西尔弗曼，做梦还有什么意义？而且你甚至都出不来。她就住在那个破公寓里，他去那儿接她。所以我，当萨拉·西尔弗曼终于买了一栋房子时，甚至算不上什么大房子，只是一栋小房子。我也接受了。我就想，你可是萨拉·西尔弗曼。我们不想看到你也和我们挤在破街区里。对，对，对。我们要有梦想。对。然后当你到了，当你去了她家，在一群人中让我笑出声的那句台词是……毛巾，你说了关于毛巾的事。我从来没见过，你出生时带什么毛巾，死的时候就用什么毛巾。我不知道什么叫新毛巾。
Solomon finally bought a house, and it's not even, it's a, it's a small house, but it's a house.
I'll take it. I'm like, you're Sarah Silverman. We don't want to see that you're in the
fucking block with us. Right, right, right. We want to dream. Right. And then when you got,
when you went over there, the one line that made me laugh out loud amongst men.
was towels, you said something about towels.
I've never, whatever towel you're born with
is the towel you die with.
I don't know new towels.
我从来没听说过新毛巾，因为她说我们刚给泳池买了新毛巾。我说，新毛巾。对，对我来说，毛巾是跟房子一起建好的。我都不知道它们是从哪来的。就像，我从来没有过，除非它是把你的皮给去角质搓掉，
I never heard of new towels
because she said we just got new towels for the pool.
I said, new towels.
Right.
Like, to me, a towels built with the house.
I don't know where they even came from.
Like, I have never even,
like, unless it's exfoliating your skin off,
否则它根本擦不干你，像这种新毛巾毛茸茸的。顺便说一句，新毛巾一点也不好。新毛巾只有洗了大约20次、洗掉上面那层浆洗物质、终于开始吸水的时候才好用。听起来我们这儿有个专家。请继续。这对我来说确实是个事。
it's not drying you, like this new fluffy towel.
By the way, there's nothing great about a new towel.
New towel ain't good until about 20 washes
and it gets all that film off of it
and it finally gets thirsty.
It sounds like we got an expert here.
Go ahead.
It's actually a thing for me.
在 Netflix 上看《醒醒吧》。顺便说一句，罗比，你简直不敢相信杰森用的毛巾和床上用品。那绝对是最高级别的。不，确实是。我知道怎么做出一条吸水力强的毛巾。你需要一条吸水的毛巾，好吗？
Wake up on Netflix.
By the way, Robbie, you can't believe
the towels and the betting that Jason is
involved with.
It is of the highest level.
No, it is.
I know how to create a thirsty towel.
You need a thirsty towel, okay?
不然的话，你知道吗？我挺佩服杰森这一点的。听着，我可不想去杰森·巴特曼家或者开车路过它。这他妈的，他太麻木不仁了。对。好吧。就像，我希望那是个大门。
Otherwise, you know what?
I'm into that for Jason.
Look, I don't want to go to Jason Baitman's house
or drive by it.
And it's fucking, he's insensitive.
Yeah.
Okay.
Like, I want it to be a gate.
我希望像……哦，是个大门。不是那种，我们想要梦想。我们想要看到明星们过着明星般的生活。如果他们没有，我心中的某些东西就会破碎。别担心。别担心。他正在满足你所有的幻想。
I want to like...
Oh, it's a gate.
It's not like, we want to dream.
We want to see that the stars are living like stars.
Something breaks from me if they're not.
Don't worry.
He's fulfilling all your fantasies.
嘿，嘿，东汉普顿（East Hampton）。酷。他就在那儿。我太喜欢了。他就在房子里。你也是，笑什么笑。好吧。欧内斯特·博格宁（Ernest Borgnine）在杰森家里的每个房间都自慰过。
Hey, hey, East Hampton.
Cool.
He's in there.
I love it.
He's in the house.
You too, chuckles.
Okay.
Ernest Borgneine jerked off in every room in Jason's house.
这是一个真实的故事。太棒了。这正是我想要的。我想要这些故事。这就是好莱坞巴比伦，好吗？我们马上回来。好的，回到节目中。但是，罗比，你知道的，就像你说的关于去这些人家的事。
That's a true story.
Fantastic.
That's what I want.
I want these stories.
That's Hollywood Babylon, okay?
We'll be right back.
All right, back to the show.
But, Robbie, you know, the same thing about what you said about, like, going to these people's houses.
因为当《威尔与格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）刚开播时，你知道的，我成了人们都知道的那种人物。同性恋偶像。我被推入了那个世界。被推入。哦，我敢肯定同性恋者讨厌他。因为同性恋男士都想当搞笑的那一个。所以当真的有一个搞笑的人出现时，就会想，哦，他觉得自己是吗？
Because when Will and Grace first started, and, you know, I became this thing that people knew.
Gay icon.
And I was thrust into this world.
Thrust.
Oh, I'm sure gay people hated him.
Because gay men all want to be the funny one.
So when there's actually a funny one,
like, oh, does he think he?
是这样吗，肖恩？你在同性恋社群里遭到过强烈抵制吗，肖恩？无可奉告。好吧。但我总是，但我开始觉得……强烈抵制。我没说水花四溅（back splash）。
Yeah.
Is that true, Sean?
Did you get backlash in the gay community, Sean?
No comment.
Okay.
But I always, but I started feeling like...
Backlash.
I didn't say back splash.
继续。熊族强烈抵制（bear backlash）。怎么样？你遭到过什么熊族强烈抵制吗？别转身。别看着我。别转身。别看着我。
Keep going.
Bear backlash.
How about that?
Do you get any bare backlash?
Don't turn around.
Don't look at me.
哦，你他妈看着我。对，继续，继续，好，很好。然后我发现，所以我开始过上那种我只在杂志或其他地方读到过的生活。然后我发现自己身处一个我们大家都认识的超级富豪的豪宅里。那里有一个管家迎接我。然后，你不能上楼，你不能去这个房间，你可以去那个房间。我听你谈过类似的事情，对吧，类似的经历，关于当你第一次，所谓“成功”或者其他什么的时候，你开始发现，
Oh, you fucking look at me.
Yeah, go ahead, go ahead, good, good.
So then I found, so I started living this life that I only read about, like, in magazines or whatever.
And then I found myself inside this one mansion of this very wealthy person that we all know.
And there's this, this butler there to greet me.
And there's, you can't go upstairs, you can't go in this room, you can go in this room.
And I heard you talking about a similar thing, right, similar experience about how,
when you first, quote, unquote, make it or whatever, you start, that it's much more ease and comfort.
和那些没有钱的人一起闲逛要轻松舒适得多，因为和没钱的人在一起是没有那么多规矩的。我超喜欢你谈论这个。对，就像我想念，你知道的，当你去一个有钱人的家里或者别的什么地方，你不能，一切都像是，你只能围着这个庞大的岛台站着。它太大了。
hanging out with people who don't have money
because there's no rules with people who don't have money.
And I loved when you talked about that.
Yeah, like I miss, like, you know,
when you go to a rich person's house or something
and you can't, like, everything is like,
you're kind of standing around this, like, gargantuan island.
It's, like, too big.
就像，厨房岛台大得离谱。我在想，我们能靠得更近点吗？比如，我们能聊聊天吗？就像，你居然生活在这座大得离谱的岛台旁边。确实。而且你不能，冰箱是不能随便开的，太疯狂了。就好像你不能真的吃零食。而相比之下，你知道的，当我只是去某人的公寓时，
Like, the kitchen island has gone.
I'm like, can we get closer?
Like, can we chat?
Like, it's just you live at this gargantuan island.
True.
And you can't, you don't go in the fridge is crazy.
And it's like you don't really like snack.
Versus like, you know, when I would just go to somebody's apartment,
那房子就像个垃圾堆。对。你知道的，空调是用一个小东西勉强撑着。那里有薯片，有多力多滋。你可以拿一罐雪碧。你可以喝，那里有，你知道的，有威士忌什么的。然后你就在那儿吐槽别人。你就在那儿。
it's like the house is a dump.
Right.
You know, the air conditioner's held on by a little thing.
And there's chips, there's Doritos.
You can grab a Sprite.
You can have, there's like, you know, there's like whiskey, whatever.
And you're just shitting on people.
You're sitting there.
你把每个人都吐槽了一遍。我讨厌那个碧池。对。那个碧池真该死。对。然后你们就在那儿放松。整个过程，有时邻居在那儿，你就冲他喊：去你的！
You're shitting on everyone.
I hate that bitch.
Right.
That bitch could get fucked.
And you're just chilling.
And the whole thing and sometimes the neighbor
and you go, fuck you.
好吧，去你的！就像，什么事都没有，你们只是在放松。就像，这根本无所谓。比如，你把酒喝完。你洒了点。谁在乎呢？对。但相反的情况是，你总是觉得自己时刻处于紧绷状态，
Well, fuck you.
Like, nothing, you're just chill.
Like, it doesn't matter.
Like, you finish your drink out.
You did a spill.
Who cares?
Right.
But then the opposite is like you always feel like you're on,
我不知道，你必须注意你的一举一动。你必须注意你把杯子放在哪张桌子上。对，并不是为了美化贫穷，因为贫穷在其他方面都很糟糕。顺便说一句，为了这种松弛感而受穷真不值得。但仅仅是社交部分。仅仅是社交部分很棒。如果可以的话，比起贫穷，我还是会选择富有，哪怕要付出社交上的代价。
I don't know, you have to watch every move you make.
You have to watch every glass where you set your glass.
Yeah, and not to glorify being poor
because it's horrible for everything else.
By the way, not worth it for the chill.
But just the socializing.
Just the socializing part is good.
Would take rich over poor even with the socializing.
话虽如此，有些事情我们确实做得更好。你知道你应该怎么做，罗比，考虑一下这个。你知道的，你现在算是在实现你的梦想，你的特辑大获成功，你正在成为一个喜剧偶像。怎么样，好吧？而且这是真的。这是建立在牛逼轰轰的天才之上的。你要做的是，当你建造你的梦想之家时，
That said, there's certain things that we did better.
You know what you ought to do, Robbie, consider this.
You know, you're now sort of realizing your dream,
your specialist's huge, you're becoming a comedic icon.
How about that, okay?
And it's true.
And it's based on fucking unreal talent.
What you've got to do is when you build your dream house,
你的梦想豪宅，建一栋漂亮的、他妈的毛巾齐全的房子，六套毛巾，床单，他妈的不管什么，啦啦啦。但厨房得是一个他妈的烂摊子。厨房必须是一个非常小的、带有一张破桌子、破冰箱、有双立人多力多滋和雪碧的狭小厨房，还有你他妈想要的任何东西。一个小炉子，
your dream mansion, build out a beautiful
fucking towels, six sets of towels,
sheets, fucking whatever, blah.
But the kitchen is a fucking wreck.
The kitchen is a tiny little kitchen
with a fucking table, shit fridge,
Doritos and Sprite, and whatever the fuck you want.
A little stove, a little electric stove
一个带电热盘的小电炉。角落里还得养一只山羊，你用来挤奶。你知道我的意思吗？就这么干。房子的其余部分不可思议。对，对吧？一只山羊。我其实觉得这有……人们挺喜欢这个的。这有点像那个表情包，当希拉里·克莱恩，还记得希拉里·克莱恩第一次看到工人阶级家庭厨房时的那个表情包吗？
with a coil. You got a goat in the corner
that you get your milk from.
You know what I mean? Just do that. The rest of the house is incredible.
Yeah, right?
A goat.
I actually think there's...
Good likes of this. It's kind of like giving like the meme when Hillary Clinton,
remember the meme of Hillary Clinton seeing like a working class family's kitchen for the first time?
简直是史上最棒的事情之一。我觉得这付出了你的全部。我觉得那张照片的意思就是，哦，对，他们跟我们不一样。顺便说一句，你知道你可以做什么吗？既然我真的要这么干了，因为你知道很多富人是怎么做的吗？他们有两个厨房，对吧？这非常流行。你以前见过这个吗？不，这对我来说挺新鲜的。请讲。所以他们做的是，他们进去，有一个带岛台什么的厨房，看起来棒极了、美极了。对。然后那是大家聚会的地方。而在那后面，
Each one of the greatest things. I think it cost you're everything. I think it was just that one picture
where it's like, oh yeah, they're not like us. By the way, you know what you could do?
Now that I'm really going, because you know what a lot of rich people do is they have two kitchens, right?
This is very popular. Have you seen this before? No, this is new for me. Please.
So what they do is they have, so you go in, they have the kitchen with the island and stuff and it looks great and beautiful.
Yeah. And then that's where everybody hangs out. And then behind the
They have the actual working kitchen.
Sorry, Jason, what is that?
他们有真正的功能性厨房。抱歉，杰森，那是什么？就像有个奴隶，肖恩带着个铃铛在那儿？现在还是这样吗？他们在厨房后面真的有一个功能性厨房。对，他们有两个。你可以有一个你的破烂厨房，但在后面藏一个真正功能齐全、漂亮而且应有尽有的厨房。这就像个布景。杰森真的纠结上了。
So there's like a slave, Sean's there with a bell.
Is that what's going on still?
They have literally a working kitchen behind the kitchen.
Right, they have two.
You could have your shit kitchen,
but behind have a real working kitchen that's beautiful and all the stuff.
It's like a set.
Jason is really hung up.
他还在想着角落里的那只山羊。如果杰森至少没有两个厨房，我就不干了。这就没意思了。我再也不敢做梦了。如果他至少没有两个厨房，那就什么都没了。你现在介于贫穷和富有之间，还是你现在已经稳稳地迈入富有阶层，或者你仍然觉得自己很穷？
He's still the goat in the corner of the middle.
If Jason doesn't have at least two kitchens, I'm quitting.
Like, there's no point.
I can't dream anymore.
Like, if he doesn't have at least two kitchens,
There's nothing left.
Where are you in between poor and rich,
or are you firmly enriched now, or are you still in poor?
不，我，我觉得我的收入大概相当于一个相当成功的牙医可能赚到的水平。好吧，那是富有。那相当不错。那是富有。极其富有。看在上帝的份上，你身后都有一个下拉训练器了。不，我知道。等我装上杠铃，你们这帮碧池就全完了。
No, I'm, I think I'm like what a pretty successful dentist might make.
Okay, that's rich.
That's very good.
It's rich.
It's extremely rich.
You got a pull-down machine behind you, for Christ's sake.
No, I know.
Once I get the weights, it's over for you.
等我把这些配重片装上去，练出那个V字形背阔肌的时候，你们就等着瞧吧。你身后有绿植吗？你身后有绿植什么的吗？这个公寓，其实我正身处我的梦想之中。比如，我们租了这间公寓，但房东已经93岁了。我希望我们能再租它10年。我们不知道他还活着没有，或者怎么样。我们不知道。
Bitches, once I get these weights on here and I get that V-shaped going.
You got the greenery behind you?
You got greenery behind you and shit?
This apartment, actually I am in one of my dreams.
Like, we rent this apartment, but the landlord is 93.
And I am hoping we can rent it for 10 more years.
We don't know if he's alive or what.
We don't know.
我们好久没听到他的消息了。我尽量不向他索取任何东西。但这绝对是梦想中的情况。我住在一间漂亮的公寓里。对。而且我喜欢公寓。我觉得我更有安全感。我得努力才能买得起
We haven't heard from him.
And I try not to ask him for anything.
But this is a dream situation.
I live in a beautiful apartment.
Yeah.
And I like an apartment.
I think I'm a little safer.
I have to work up to.
一栋房子，因为我不太喜欢那种一出门就是街道的设计，要么得有大门那种，但随后我又觉得，我永远不会……我对房子的想法是，比如说你想喝杯水，也许吧，杰森——所以你要下楼，这得花多长时间？路程还挺远的好吧，假设你只是想喝杯水，这得花点时间。我有一个骆驼背水袋（CamelBak），能让我从……你有吗？你楼上有迷你冰箱吗？大家都在用迷你冰箱吗，还是那显得很穷？
a house because I don't like that the door
and then it's like street
I need either the gate thing
but then I'm like
I would never like
what I thought about when I with a house
is like let's say you want a glass of water
and maybe Jason okay so you're going
能用的话，其实挺好的。很久以前，我在 Netflix 上看了一部叫《离经叛道》（Unorthodox）的剧集，如果你还没看过，真的非常非常棒。太棒了。那是一部惊艳的剧集。如果你没看过，它真的很棒。讲的是一个女人试图逃离成为
downstairs like what is
the travel time
it takes a bit
let's say you just want a cup of water
it takes a bit I got a camelback that gets me from the
you do do you have
Have a mini fridge upstairs?
Are people doing the mini or is that poor?
哈西德犹太人以及那种文化和生活方式的传统。而且因为家庭关系的羁绊，很难逃出来。因为他们一直把你拉回去。没错。教父。好吧，继续。所以告诉我成长是什么感觉，因为现在我对这一切唯一的参考就是这个，
When it's working, it's nice.
So a long time ago,
I saw a scripted show
called Unorthodox on Netflix, which if you
haven't seen it, it's really, really great.
Fantastic. It was an amazing show.
If you haven't seen it, it's great. It's about a woman who is
trying to escape the traditions of
这对了解哈西德家庭的生活对我来说非常有教育意义。在那种环境下长大是什么感觉，当时你知道自己是同性恋，然后出柜了吗？我不知道我是同性恋。我完全不知道。我不是那种懂这些的小孩。对。我可没想过这事。
being an Hasidic Jew and that culture
and that lifestyle. And it's hard to get out because of the
family dynamics. Because they keep pulling you back
in. That's right.
The godfather.
Okay, keep going up.
So tell me what it was like growing up,
because now that's the only reference I have for anything
当我发现时，当我意识到“我是同性恋”时，我的反应是：我觉得不是吧。你是怎么发现的？是收到了邮件还是怎么的？不，我直到大概17岁时才发现，当时有一个非常奇怪的意大利女孩。她……
because it's very educational for me inside the life of a Hasidic family.
What was it like growing up in that, knowing you were gay,
and then coming out?
I didn't know I was gay.
I had no idea.
I wasn't a kid who knew anything like this.
Yeah.
I didn't want to come about it.
好吧，这部分请说慢一点。对，不，事情是这样的，当时我在学校，
When I found out, when I was like, I'm gay, I'm like, I don't think so.
How'd you find out?
Was it by mail or was it?
No, I only found out, like, maybe at 17,
there was this really weird Italian girl.
And she...
Okay, slow down through here, please.
Yeah, no, so what happened was I was at school,
我们可以一直聊天聊到早上五点，我们一直在聊天。但后来我们得选修体育课。我17岁了，好吧？所以我们有……为了下学期，我们得选体育课，我就想，我得试着选进……羽毛球课，我总是想选一门非常轻松的体育课，因为我是犹太人，而且思想比较超前。我听说高尔夫是一门很容易拿A的课。所以我打算选高尔夫。
and we would chat till, like, five in the morning, we would chat.
But then we had to sign up for gym.
I'm 17, okay?
So we had...
For next semester, we had to do gyms,
and I was like, I'm going to try and get into...
badminton, I would always try and get like a very easy gym because I'm Jewish and
unauthoric. I was like, I heard golf is an easy A. So I'm going to try and do golf.
好的。好的，因为那个老师，博尚（Beouchamp），我到现在还记得他的名字。他显然，他只希望你肯尝试。他超级热爱高尔夫。所以只要你肯尝试，他就给你一个A。在她的课堂上，这就叫平时分。他只是想让大家享受高尔夫这项运动。所以我当时就想，但他的课很快就满了，因为这是最轻松的课。对。然后她就说，
Okay. Okay, because the teacher, Beauchamp, I still remember his name. He apparently, like,
he just wants you to try. He loves golf. And so if you try, he gives you an A. Like,
it's A for effort in his class. He just wants people to enjoy the game of golf. So I was like,
but his class fills up because it's the easiest class. Right. And she goes.
what I'm going to do, there's a camping intensive.
Dike, okay?
Camping seemed like the hardest gym you could do.
Like, yes, you didn't have to do gym every...
我要去参加野营集训。拉拉，懂了吧？野营看起来就像你能选的最难的体育课。对吧，你不需要上常规的体育课……好吧，没有哪个犹太人会想去参加野营。野营集训。对，所以你上你的体育课。只需要一周，但你这学期的体育课就修完了。与其每周去一次高尔夫球课，或者每周去一次羽毛球课，这是在公立大学。
Okay, no Jew was even thinking to join the camping.
Camping intensive.
Yeah, so you do your gym.
It's one week, but your gym for the semester is done.
Instead of going to golf once a week,
or instead of going at badminton once a week,
this is in public college.
in Montreal.
在蒙特利尔。他们在大学里依然要求你上体育课。对，对。这是什么，赛日普（Cégep）？赛日普的东西。哇。好吧。好吧，所以这不是赛日普。所以她当时说，我要去参加野营。
They made you do a gym still in college.
Right, right.
This is what, Sechip?
Seagip thing.
Wow.
Okay.
Okay, so this isn't Seijep.
So she was like, I'm doing camping.
他们在大学时还是让你去上体育课。对，对。这是什么，Sechip？Seagip之类的事。哇。好吧。好吧，所以这不是Seijep。所以她当时说，我在露营。
I'm like, is she demented?
It's like the hardest gym you could do.
Like, what?
A week?
Like, I'd rather do badminton once.
So then she starts talking to me and she goes,
there's this bisexual or something on the trip.
What if we share a tent?
我都觉得，她是不是脑子有病？那是你能去的最魔鬼的健身房。就，什么？一个星期？拜托，我宁愿去打一次羽毛球。然后她开始跟我聊天，她说，这次旅行里有个双性恋什么的。要不咱俩合住一个帐篷？
And she kisses me.
And I go, what are you fucking gay?
I'm like, call the police.
Like, what's wrong with you?
Like, what is she doing?
I'm like, like, this scenario blew me away.
Like, I'm like, is this girl okay?
Like, what do you mean if she tried to kiss you?
然后她就亲了我。我说，你特么是个同性恋吧？我都想报警了。就，你脑子有病吧？她到底在干嘛？我就觉得，这个剧情把我整不会了。我就想，这女孩脑子没事吧？什么叫她试着亲你？
Literally call the police.
Like, this is insane.
You have to tell the teacher on this girl.
Like, this is crazy.
Right.
So I'm like, you've got to go to the teacher.
Like, I don't know.
I just get offline.
简直得报警。这太离谱了。你必须得去向老师告发这个女孩。这太疯狂了。对。所以我就觉得，你必须去找老师。反正我不知道。我直接下线了。
I'm going to bed.
Right.
Then she starts talking to me.
She's like, this camp.
She's coming up.
And then she tells me the girl, they did their camping intensive.
The girl kissed her.
I'm like, okay, this girl's fucking gay.
我要睡觉了。对。然后她开始跟我聊天。她说，这个营地。她要来了。然后她告诉我那个女孩，她们进行了野营特训。那个女孩亲了她。我想，好吧，这女孩特么就是个同性恋。
I am not like, what, oh, we're.
I was the most homophobic person you could be.
Sure.
Okay, because I probably knew about it.
But I would test the waters.
Like, I would ask my older sister, I'd say,
what do you think about gay people?
Because one of my sisters told me Rosie O'Donnell was gay.
我可不是，什么，哦，我们是。我当时可是你能想象到的最直男（直女）恐同的人。真的。好吧，因为我可能听说过这事。但我会试探一下。比如，我会问我大姐，我说，你对同性恋怎么看？因为我的一个姐姐告诉我罗西·欧唐纳是同性恋。
And I was like, that's impossible.
She loves Tom Cruise.
Right.
Sure.
Like, thinking, like, she's like, she's a dyke.
Wake up.
Right.
And I just, like, didn't want to, like, but I asked one of my older sisters, a different sister.
然后我说，这不可能。她深爱着汤姆·克鲁斯。对。真的。就觉得，她觉得，她就是个死同性恋。醒醒吧。对。然后我，就，不想，但，我问了我大姐，另一个姐姐。
I said, what do you think about these gay people?
Because Chaya says that Rosie O'Donnell's gay.
And she's like, if God wanted gay people, he would have made Adam and Steve.
Right.
Not Adam and Eve.
And I said, wow.
When she's right, she's right.
That was fact.
我说，你对这些同性恋怎么看？因为查亚说罗西·欧唐纳是同性恋。然后她说，如果上帝想要同性恋，他就会创造亚当和史蒂夫。对。而不是亚当和夏娃。我说，哇。她这话没毛病。这可是事实。
Who was this?
Your mom said that?
No, this was one of my older sisters.
One of my sisters thought Rosie O'Don was gay,
didn't give a shit about being religious.
The other one was still quite religious.
I was like, if God wanted.
And I was like, wow, she's so wise.
这是谁说的？你妈说的吗？不是，这是我大姐。我其中一个姐姐觉得罗西·欧唐纳是同性恋，对宗教根本不在乎。另一个则相当笃信宗教。我说，如果上帝想要……当时我就想，哇，她太明智了。
Yeah.
Like, she hit me with an indisputable fact.
Sure.
But then what happened?
But then how did you?
So then this girl, she and, you know, she was persistent.
She wore me down.
The camper.
对。她用一个无可辩驳的事实把我给整不会了。确实。但后来呢？但后来你是怎么？所以后来这个女孩，她，而且，你知道，她很坚持。她把我磨平了。那个营员。
Okay, my father was going to send me.
I had no money, and out of nowhere, I really tried to reach out to my father if he could send me.
I was living on my own.
I was 17.
I was in school and working full-time.
But I needed like $200 for the semester, or I couldn't even.
It was a public college, but I think it at least cost it $200.
And my father somehow came through with $200.
好吧，我父亲本来打算资助我。我身无分文，情急之下，我真的试着联系我父亲，看他能不能资助我。我自己一个人住。我17岁。我一边上学一边打全职工。但我这学期需要大约200美元，否则我甚至都不能。这是一所公立大学，但我觉得它至少得花200美元。而我父亲不知怎么的真的寄来了200美元。
My father's like, it's going to be at Western Union.
And I'm like, I can't believe my father.
sending me money. First of all, nobody had money. So, but I was like, it really meant a lot to me
that he was like doing this lifelong, sending me $200. And she was like, I know where the Western
Union is. Because I never heard of it. I didn't really know how to get the money. She walked me
all the way there. Did she yell this to you from an open car window?
No, literally. We walked, we talked for eight hours. I wrote her name in Hebrew.
Letters. She was interested in my background.
我父亲说，钱在西联汇款。我说，我简直不敢相信我父亲给我寄钱。首先，谁也没有钱。但我觉得，他能这么做，真的对我意义重大，一生中第一次给我寄了200美元。然后她说我知道西联汇款在哪。因为我从来没听说过。我其实根本不知道怎么去拿这笔钱。她一路陪着我走了过去。她是在车窗打开的情况下对你大喊这个的吗？没有，真的。我们走了，我们聊了八个小时。我用希伯来字母写下了她的名字。字母。她对我的背景很感兴趣。
And it was something different than a friend.
And then the year we were graduating, it was the end of the semester now.
And our teacher was throwing like, you know, an end of the year.
Everybody could exchange numbers.
Everybody could, you know, he wanted us to, like, get together in the summer and share what we're reading and all this stuff.
This is Beauchamp.
No, but, and by the way, Beauchamp was huge.
What's that?
而且这跟一般朋友不一样。然后到了我们毕业的那一年，现在已经是学期末了。我们的老师举办了一个，你知道，学期末派对。每个人都可以交换电话号码。每个人都可以，你知道，他希望我们在夏天聚在一起，分享我们的阅读内容之类的一切。这是博尚吗？不，而且，顺便说一句，博尚太牛了。什么？
And he just stood there.
Teacher.
And you went one by one.
He taught you how to swing.
And that was the end of the class.
It was, I got into golf and it was worth everything.
Sure.
So that's, if Beauchamp's still teaching at Dawson, take his class.
然后他就站在那儿。老师。然后你们一个接一个上去。他教你挥杆。这就是那节课的全部内容。我迷上了高尔夫，这太值得了。真的。所以，如果博尚还在道森教书，去选他的课。
Sure.
It's like an hour of meditation.
There's nothing even to do.
He doesn't care if you're good at golf.
And it's a guarantee day.
It's a easy A.
So, yeah, so at the end of the year, we go to this bar, this student bar that the teacher was going to buy maybe two pictures or whatever.
Again, we're like 18 now, 17, 18.
真的。就像一小时的冥想。甚至什么都不用做。他才不在乎你高尔夫打得好不好。而且这是稳拿的学分。这是一门轻松拿A的课。所以，对，所以在学期末，我们去了一家酒吧，一个学生酒吧，老师可能会出钱买两扎啤酒什么的。再说一次，我们现在18岁了，17、18岁。
18, Montreal.
So keep in mind, this is not like a U.S.
They don't like alcohol.
Like, everybody drinks from 14 there.
It's not like a thing.
Right.
So, and we go, and she goes,
she goes the night before we're chatting to like four in the morning.
18岁，在蒙特利尔。所以记住，这不像美国。他们不讨厌酒精。在那里，每个人14岁就开始喝酒了。这根本不算个事。对。所以，我们去了，然后她说，就在前一天晚上，我们一直聊到凌晨四点。
And she goes, what if I kissed you?
She tells me this.
And I'm like, what are you fucking gay?
I block delete her.
Yeah, there you go.
Block delete.
She's out of my life.
That's eight.
然后她说，如果我亲了你呢？她跟我这么说。我说，你特么是个同性恋吧？我拉黑并删除了她。对，就是这样。拉黑删除。她滚出我的生活了。那就八。
We go to the end of the summer.
or sorry, beginning, end of the semester,
hang at the bar at the afternoon,
like San Cassette, five to seven.
I go to the bathroom.
She goes to the bathroom.
First of all, it's a huge place,
but I don't even know.
我们迎来了夏天结束。或者抱歉，开始，学期末，下午在酒吧闲逛，就像圣卡塞特酒吧，五点到七点。我去洗手间。她也去洗手间。首先，那是个很大的地方，但我甚至不知道。
She gets in the stall.
I get in the stall,
and she just kisses me.
Come on.
And I right away with kissing the back.
She followed you into the stall.
Yeah, she's a predator.
It happens, both sides.
她进了隔间。我也进了隔间，然后她直接亲了我。拜托。我马上就回吻了她。她跟着你进了隔间？对，她是个掠食者。这种事都有，双方都有。
We forget.
You say, so she's a predator.
So she kissed you, then you kissed her back.
Yeah, and I remember touching her stomach, and I was like, wow, you have abs.
That's the first thing I ever said.
Sure.
But I didn't know of abs, really, but I was like, oh, this is abs.
我们忘了。我们忘了。你说，所以她是个掠食者。所以她亲了你，然后你回吻了她。对，我记得摸了摸她的肚子，我说，哇，你有腹肌。这是我对她说的第一句话。确实。但我其实根本不懂什么是腹肌，但我当时就想，哦，这就是腹肌。
And that was it.
And then I was gay secret.
But I never thought about being gay my whole life.
I really didn't think of anything, but not being poor.
And then how did that go over with the folks?
Well, my father is still Hasidic.
I have no relationship with him, so I don't know.
He wrote me, he heard about it and he wrote me one email.
就这样。然后这就是我的同性恋秘密。但我一辈子都没想过当同性恋。我真的什么都没想，只想不当穷光蛋。然后家里人对这事反应如何？呃，我父亲还是哈西德派。我和他没有联系，所以我不知道。他写信给我，他听说了这事，给我写了一封电子邮件。
This is not befitting behavior for a daughter of Israel.
Okay.
So that was that.
And I'm not Israeli or anything, but I think he's talking more biblically, Israel as the Jewish people.
Right.
Oh, no, he said the behavior is promiscuous and not befitting.
And I only had one girlfriend.
I really was not permiscuous.
这不符合以色列女儿的端庄行为。好吧。事情就是这样。我又不是以色列人什么的，但我认为他说的更多是从《圣经》角度，把以色列作为犹太人民。对。哦，不，他说这种行为淫荡且不得体。而我只有一个女朋友。我真的不淫荡。
So I resented that.
Yep.
I was not like a hoe.
No.
I was monogamous.
Right.
And even if I wanted to be a ho, so be it.
But anyway, who cares?
所以我对此很不满。对。我又不是个荡妇。不是。我很专一。对。而且就算我想当个荡妇，那又怎样。不管怎样，谁在乎呢？
Right, exactly.
And then my mother didn't, no, by this point my family was not that religious.
And I was also a little more removed by my family.
I came back to, like, I was living on my own.
I was like not living in my mother's house.
Like, my big world was my social world.
Yeah.
Like it was about friends.
对，没错。然后我妈妈没有，不，到这个时候我的家人已经没那么宗教化了。而且我也跟家人保持了一点距离。我回来后，就像，我一个人住。我没有住在我妈妈家里。就像，我的整个世界就是我的社交圈。对。一切都是关于朋友。
It was about this.
And they thought it.
It was weird.
They didn't take it well.
Oh, really?
Yeah, even though gay was still a thing and we weren't as religious, they were still
conservative.
I still like...
一切都是关于这个。他们觉得这很奇怪。他们接受不了。哦，真的吗？对，尽管同性恋已经不是什么新鲜事了，而且我们也没那么宗教化了，但他们依然很保守。我还是……
Right.
The community I then became a part of was like, yes, not as fanatic as we were, but still
conservative.
Okay.
Yeah.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
Great.
对。我后来加入的那个社群也是，是的，虽然不像我们以前那么狂热，但依然很保守。好吧。对。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。太棒了。
So this is a good segue to talk about Gabby, your wife, Gabby.
Now, I don't know that these two know anything about your wife.
Maybe they do, but it's such a fascinating story.
Gabby Wendy was the Bachelorette on the show Bachelorette.
And then you ended up with her, which is such a great.
My wife had 25 boyfriends four years ago,
and I got the final fucking rose in the end.
Hey, all right.
所以这是一个很好的过渡，可以聊聊加比，你的妻子，加比。现在，我不知道这两位对你的妻子了解多少。也许他们知道，但这真是一个极其迷人的故事。加比·温迪曾是《黄金单身女郎》节目里的单身女郎。然后你最后和她走到了一起，这真是太棒了。我妻子四年前有25个男朋友，而我最后得到了特么的最后一朵玫瑰。嘿，太棒了。
Isn't that wild?
It's such a great story.
How did that happen?
I don't know, and I have nothing when the fellas,
because I told her not to come out.
I had such a brutal story.
You know, I said, because she said she's going to think about coming out.
I'm like, I don't think we need to do that anymore.
这不是很疯狂吗？这故事太棒了。这是怎么发生的？我不知道，而且当小伙子们的时候我什么也没有，因为我叫她别出来。我有个惨痛的故事。你知道，我说，因为她说她要考虑出来。我说，我觉得我们不需要再做那种事了。
Uh-huh.
I suggest.
Wait, wait.
Was she gay when she was on the show?
So she was always, and I won't fully speak to her, but I will a little bit.
She wasn't always like, she was unsure.
She was one of those girls.
Like, she had had, she's repressed.
嗯哼。我建议。等等，等等。她上节目的时候是同性恋吗？所以她一直都是，我不会完全代表她说话，但我会说一点。她并不总是那样，她很不确定。她是那种女孩。比如，她有过，她被压抑了。
Like when she was younger, she had gay thoughts, but her parents were so anti.
That she just, and she could go the other way.
She could go with dudes.
So she just did that.
And I think the way she describes it was, first of all, if you're hot and you can get onto the Bachelor as a contestant, she typically tells girls do it.
She was a nurse and I see a nurse for years.
And for her being on the Bachelor first as a contestant was like, she's like, you go on one date with the dude once a week.
And then the rest of the week you're like in Portugal with all these girls hanging out.
比如她年轻的时候，有过同性恋的念头，但她的父母太反对了。以至于她只是，她也可以走另一条路。她可以和男人在一起。所以她就那么做了。而且我觉得她描述的方式是，首先，如果你很辣，并且能作为女嘉宾上《黄金单身汉》，她通常会告诉女孩们去试试。她是一名护士，我当了好几年护士。对她来说，先作为女嘉宾上《黄金单身汉》就像是，她说，你一周和那个男的约会一次。然后一周剩下的时间你就像在葡萄牙和所有这些女孩一起闲逛。
Like it's a free European like, she's like they take you everywhere.
You have one shooting day a week.
Yeah.
And it's like I paid for amazing vacation.
She got to see it.
But then she got chosen as the Bachelorette.
Right.
Now she's the girl with the 25 dudes.
就像是一场免费的欧洲旅行一样，她说他们带你去任何地方。你一周只有一个拍摄日。对。就像我为一次绝妙的假期付了钱。她得以去见识这一切。但后来她被选为《黄金单身女郎》。对。现在她是那个拥有25个男人的女孩了。
Right.
So then you're working a lot.
You're going on a day-to-day or whatever.
And I think as it started to dwindle down, she was like, I don't think any of these.
Right, right, right.
She was getting more pressure.
And did you know her during that time or did you meet her after the show?
I met her after the show, but I did watch the end of her season
对。所以你得疯狂工作。你每天都在约会什么的。而且我觉得随着人数开始减少，她就想，我觉得这里面没有一个。对，对，对。她承受的压力越来越大。那你在那期间认识她的，还是节目结束后才认识她的？我在节目结束后认识她的，但我的确看了她那一季的结尾
and without knowing it was her.
When I met her, of course, she's not in the gown.
And, you know, it's a very different.
How did you guys meet?
Was it like an industry function?
Or it's just like-
No, we met outside.
Out in the wilderness?
而且当时并不知道那是她。当我见到她时，当然，她没有穿礼服。而且，你知道，这是非常不同的。你们是怎么认识的？是在某个业内活动上吗？还是就像——没有，我们在外面认识的。在荒野中？
Yeah, we met just outside.
And a camping trip?
No, could you imagine?
We met, I was meeting a friend after,
I miss a lot of evenings because I do stand up,
so I miss a lot of dinners and stuff like that.
But there was some type of an event,
and I was going to meet my friend after I had stand-up.
对，我们在外面认识的。在一次露营旅行中？不，你能想象吗？我们认识时，我是去见一个朋友，我经常错过很多夜晚因为我要做单口喜剧，所以我错过很多晚餐之类的事情。但当时有什么类型的活动，我打算在做完单口喜剧后去见我的朋友。
And I went to go meet her maybe around 10 p.m.
And we split a beer.
And by the time we were leaving, we were on the sidewalk waiting for our Ubers.
Gab was there.
There wasn't many people there, but she was there with her friends.
And that's how we met.
She was waiting for her Uber.
Oh, wow.
我大概晚上10点去见她的。我们分喝了一瓶啤酒。当我们离开的时候，我们正站在人行道上等优步。加比就在那里。那里人不多，但她和她的朋友们在那里。这就是我们认识的经过。她在等她的优步。哦，哇。
This is in L.A. or New York?
L.A.
And you're like, hey, you want to hang out sometime or have a dinner or whatever?
No.
So at first I get spotted, which is very new for me,
but a dyke like me, like a more boyish one,
was like looking at me, looking at me.
And I'm like, oh, no, we got to go.
这是在洛杉矶还是纽约？洛杉矶。然后你会说，嘿，你想什么时候一起出去玩或者吃个饭什么的吗？没有。所以起初我被认出来了，这对我来说非常新鲜，但一个像我这样的女同，那种比较像男孩的女同，一直在看着我，看着我。然后我想，哦，不，我们得走了。
I told my friend rocks.
I'm like, I'm not gay like that.
You know what I mean?
I'm like, oh, okay.
Nothing wrong.
People get mad to me.
I'm joking.
I don't mind mask for masks.
我告诉我的朋友完了。我说，我才不是那种同性恋呢。你知道我的意思吗？我说，哦，好吧。这没什么不对。人们生我的气。我在开玩笑。我不介意硬汉配硬汉。
I'm not masked for mask.
Do what you want.
It doesn't matter.
Sure.
So she comes up to me and I think she's hitting on me and, you know, I got to,
because that to me is really gay.
Like I'm gay, but there's like a boy one,
there's a girl when it kind of works again.
我可不是硬汉配硬汉。你想怎么样就怎么样。这无所谓。当然。所以她向我走来，我以为她在跟我调情，而且，你知道，我得，因为对我来说那真的很同性恋。就像我是同性恋，但有一种是男孩子气的，有一种是女孩子气的，这就又行了。
If I was masked for a mask,
I'm like, oh, bitch, you're gay.
What is that?
Nothing wrong.
I'm joking.
What is that phrase?
如果我是硬汉配硬汉，我会想，哦，碧池，你是同性恋。那是什么？这没什么不对。没什么不对。我在开玩笑。那个短语是什么？那个短语是什么？
Mask for mask.
Masculine.
Oh, wow.
It's like mask and femme.
Thank you.
Okay.
硬汉配硬汉。男性化。哦，哇。就像是T和P。谢谢。好吧。好吧。好吧。
So this butch comes, and I think she's going to hit on me.
I'm like, okay, I'm not really in the mood.
But she goes, oh, I know your comedy.
She goes, I know your comedy.
And she spotted me for my comedy, which is very new for me to happen.
And I'm like, Baruch Hashem, because.
I don't really get spotted,
but I was spotted at the perfect moment.
所以这个假小子来了，我以为她要跟我调情。我说，好吧，我其实没那个心情。但她说，哦，我知道你的喜剧。她说，我知道你的喜剧。她因为我的喜剧而认出了我，这对我来说是非常新鲜的经历，我说，巴鲁克·哈谢姆（感谢上帝），因为。我其实不常被认出来，但我却在最完美的时机被认出来了。
It's kind of if somebody catches you doing a good deed.
I was once caught giving a 20 to a homeless.
Is that amazing?
It never happens.
You know what I mean?
It's like you never get caught in a good deed.
It's not like you need, but when it happens, you go, say, say.
I'm nice.
这有点像别人抓包你在做好事。我曾经被抓到给一个无家可归的人20美元。这不是很神奇吗？这从没发生过。你知道我的意思吗？就像你永远不会在做好事时被抓到。倒不是说你需要，但当它发生时，你会说，说，说。我人很好。
It's excellent.
So it was one of these moments where I get spotted,
but it's not just me alone in the wilderness.
There's a hot, amazing girl right there.
Right.
who could hear this potentially,
and this could be impressive to such a person.
So I go, oh, I start, you know,
这太棒了。所以这是那种我被认出来的时刻，而且不只是我独自一人在荒野中。一个性感、惊艳的女孩就在那里。对。她可能会听到这个，这对这样一个人来说可能会留下深刻印象。所以我说，哦，我开始，你知道，
when you talk about to other people to hear her,
I go, oh, yeah, that is a great bit.
You know, oh, you know, I started getting in.
Loud enough for her to hear.
And then I go, well, never mind you, who are you with?
And she was with Gabby.
And she goes, oh, this Gabby, you know, the bachelor,
I was like, the bachelor's gay.
当你跟别人说话想让她听到时，我说，哦，是的，那是个超级棒的段子。你知道，哦，你知道，我开始投入进去了。声音大到足够让她听到。然后我说，好吧，管你呢，你跟谁一起来的？她和加比在一起。她说，哦，这个加比，你知道，那个单身女郎，我说，单身女郎是同性恋吗？
I don't know.
Maybe they're making a gay bachelor.
I have no idea what they're doing anymore.
Yeah, yeah.
And she goes, oh, no, she's a girl.
exploring. And I go, what are you, Dora the explorer? You're 30 years old. Who's exploring anymore?
Right, right, right. You know, you're at this place with all these dikes, it's like a dykeye bar and whatever.
So, yeah, so, so, and we really, our banter right away was excellent. Excellent. And, you know,
我不知道。也许他们在拍同性恋单身汉吧。我根本不知道他们在搞什么鬼。对，对，对。然后她说，哦，不，她是个探索者。我说，你是什么，爱探险的朵拉吗？你都30岁了。谁还在探索啊？对，对，对。你知道，你在这样一个到处都是女同的地方，这就像是一个女同酒吧什么的。所以，对，对，对，我们俩的插科打诨马上就非常精彩。非常精彩。而且，你知道，
And so how long you guys been together now? Four years. Oh, that's great. And you got married last year.
Yes, we did. Yes. And you got married in Vegas.
for $799.
Yes, we did.
And tell me what that included.
It included a limousine.
It included the Reverend, Reverend Nature.
And it included Nathan, the photographer.
所以你们现在在一起多久了？四年。哦，太棒了。你们去年结婚了。是的，我们结了。是的。你们在拉斯维加斯结的婚。只花了799美元。是的，我们结了。告诉我这都包含了什么。包含了一辆豪华轿车。包含了一位牧师，自然牧师。还包含了内森，摄影师。
Right.
Wait, sorry, you said Reverend.
That's not a rabbi?
Well, she's not anything.
She works in Vegas.
Okay.
Sure.
对。等等，抱歉，你刚才说牧师。那不是拉比吗？嗯，她什么都不是。她在拉斯维加斯工作。好吧。当然。好吧。
She's like a, what is it called?
Like an officiator.
An officiant, but, you know, not denomination.
So you didn't want to have a religious, yeah, it's adjacent to point.
Well, we can't.
We're lesbians anyway.
Right, right, right.
At that point, it's like, what are we doing?
她就像一个，那叫什么来着？就像一个证婚人。证婚人，但是，你知道，没有宗教教派。所以你不想办一场宗教婚礼，对，这倒不矛盾。嗯，我们也不能。反正我们也是女同。对，对，对。到了那个地步，就像，我们在搞什么鬼？
I know some people ask me, like, is it important for you to marry Jewish?
I'm like, what are we doing, fellas?
Yeah.
I'm like, can we?
Just try to keep track.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Let me just say this.
我知道有人问我，比如，跟犹太人结婚对你来说很重要吗？我说，我们在搞什么鬼啊，伙计们？对。我说，我们能吗？只要别忘了初心。对。你知道我的意思吗？让我这么说吧。
Let me ask you this.
So somehow, somehow you burst onto this scene.
And I say burst because it feels like you just all of a sudden we're like,
just this incredible comedian out of nowhere honestly i feel that way from the first time i saw you i was
like who the fuck is this is so good and and sean mentioned it in the intro that that malaney uh kind of
had a lot of lot to do with giving you helping you is that true right how did that come about what's that
story yeah he said he said no one's own not you i want to hear from i know but this he'll set her up
no one's owned the stage like you since james brown which i thought was great well thank you fellas
让我问你这个。所以不知怎么的，不知怎么的你突然爆红了。我之所以说爆红，是因为感觉你就像是突然之间，我们就在想，简直是一个不可思议的、横空出世的喜剧演员，老实说我从第一次看到你的时候就有这种感觉，当时我在想，这特么是谁，太厉害了。而且肖在开场白里也提到了，木兰尼对你的帮助很大，是这样的吗？对的，这事是怎么促成的？那是怎么回事？对，他说，他说没人像你一样，除了詹姆斯·布朗之外没人能把那个舞台hold住，我觉得这太棒了。好吧，谢谢你们，伙计们。
Robbie, how did it happen?
It happened out of nowhere, just like that.
He texted me.
I can read the text.
Nobody, this is an exclusive.
Bring it up.
Where did he see you?
Where was this?
罗比，这到底是怎么发生的？这简直是横空出世，就这么发生了。他给我发了短信。我可以读一下短信内容。没有人，这是一个独家爆料。念出来吧。他在哪里看到的你？是在哪？
He, I don't know what he saw, but he was sent to me out of thin air to help me.
He threw his weight behind me.
I mean, I was known to comedians.
I'm a, like, comedians do watch me.
Yep.
And I'm not saying.
somebody like I'm not very online.
I don't post my clips or anything like that.
他，我不知道他看到了什么，但他从天而降被派来帮助我。他全力支持我。我的意思是，喜剧演员们都知道我。我是个，就像，喜剧演员确实看我的表演。没错。而且我不是在说。像我这样的人，我不太上网。我从不发我的视频剪辑或类似的东西。
So to see me, you really have to see me.
And I guess he had.
And, you know, I've had people, listen to John Hamm has come to shows.
Like people who like stand up.
Old handbone got in there.
I'm just saying, you know.
So what are Melania?
What did the text say?
所以要想看到我，你真的得去看我的现场。我猜他看过了。而且，你知道的，我经历过，听着，乔·哈姆都来看过演出。就像喜欢单口喜剧的人。老哈姆也去了。我只是说，你知道的。那么木兰尼呢？短信上是怎么说的？
So he knew of me and I was doing well, but very like low key still.
He goes, hi, Robbie.
This is John Malaney.
Dan gave me your number.
I hope that's okay, a Dan that we know, a comedian.
I have been a big fan of your work for a while and really enjoyed you on WTF.
I know you have various things going on,
but if you'd ever want to talk about doing a special for Netflix,
所以他知道我，而且我当时发展得很好，但还是很低调。他发短信说，嗨，罗比。我是约翰·木兰尼。丹把你的电话号码给我了。希望这没问题，我们认识的一个丹，是个喜剧演员。我一直是你好作品的超级粉丝，非常喜欢你在《WTF》播客上的表现。我知道你手头有很多事情在忙，但如果你曾经想过谈谈为网飞（Netflix）做一档特辑，
I make them and would be very excited to work with you on one.
I think you're touring now, so maybe it's something you're eyeing.
I'm around and happy to talk whenever.
Okay, happy Sunday.
That's really nice.
And I go, which Dan, J.K., I don't care either way.
And I go, I mean, yes, of course, this has been my next dream move.
You'd be a terrific help in making this happen.
我制作过这类节目，而且会非常兴奋能和你合作一档。我想你现在正在巡演，所以也许这是你在考虑的事情。我随时都有空，很高兴随时聊聊。好的，祝你周日愉快。这真的太好了。然后我说，哪个丹，开玩笑的，我哪边都不在乎。然后我说，我的意思是，当然，这一直是我接下来的梦想之举。有你的巨大帮助，这一定能实现。
From John Mullaney, it's Robbie Hoffman.
My God, that sounds great.
Yeah, that's great.
Hope this text is okay, as I really didn't know what to write back.
As you can imagine, it's very shocking, horrifying, anxiety-inducing, surreal, and thrilling
for someone like me to receive a text like this from someone like you.
But yes, I would love to talk and work on a Netflix special with you.
Wow.
来自约翰·木兰尼，我是罗比·霍夫曼。天哪，听起来太棒了。是的，太棒了。希望这条短信没问题，因为我真的不知道该回什么。正如你所想象的，对于像我这样的人来说，收到这样一个人发来的这样一条短信，是非常震惊、惊悚、引发焦虑、超现实且令人兴奋的。但是的，我很乐意和你谈谈并合作制作一个网飞特辑。哇。
And we got it done.
Wow.
We got it done.
That's really cool.
That's fucking dope.
That's pretty great.
That's really, really good.
Just decided to throw his weight.
我们真的做到了。哇。我们做到了。这真的太酷了。太特么牛了。这相当棒。这真的，真的很棒。他决定全力支持。
He had this deal with them and he has good taste.
Yeah.
The funny dude.
And he just let me, like, I wasn't going to let anyone.
Like, he did all the production stuff and the stage and directing and this camera is going to be here and this camera.
And I was like, John, I will show up with the greatest hour of stand-up.
It's so funny.
If you ask me to what, like, I'm going to do what I do.
他和他们有这个合作协议，而且他很有品味。对。是个搞笑的家伙。他只是让我，就像，我不会让任何人。就像，他搞定了所有的制作事宜、舞台、导演，哪个摄像机会放在这儿，哪个摄像机会放在那儿。而我说，约翰，我会带着最棒的一小时单口喜剧登场。这太搞笑了。如果你让我去，就像，我会做我擅长的事。
amazing, and I will not, and he did his shit amazing.
I didn't have to worry about anything.
He's like, we're going to capture all of it.
Did you just shoot one show or did you take the best from a couple?
We had two in one night.
That's great.
And we knew after the first one, we got it.
So I could just dance the second one.
惊艳全场，而且我不会，他把他的部分做得惊艳绝伦。我根本不用操心任何事。他说，我们会捕捉到这一切。你们只拍了一场演出，还是取了多场最好的片段？我们一晚上拍了两场。太棒了。我们在第一场结束后就知道，我们搞定了。所以我第二场可以直接跳舞了。
After that first hour, I go, wow.
And I don't say this, you know, I needed to object toize it.
I think it's one of the greatest specials recorded in recent.
We haven't had a stand-up set.
And I know it's mine, but I would say, listen, I've done plays early on where I'm like,
you don't have to see that play.
I'm telling you it it it's not good.
I don't care because I'm in it that I would recommend it or something like that.
在那个第一小时结束后，我说，哇。我不是在说这个，你知道的，我需要客观地看待它。我认为这是近年录制的最伟大的特辑之一。我们已经很久没有过这样的单口喜剧专场了。我知道这是我自己的，但我要说，听着，我早期演过一些话剧，我会觉得，你们不用去看那部话剧。我告诉你们它不好。我不在乎因为我在里面演出我才会推荐它之类的。
Objectively speaking, it is one of the greatest stand-up specials.
I think that's why it's getting, you know, it happens to be mine.
Sometimes I look at it and I go, oh my, I can't believe I did that because it is so scary.
Really funny tonight.
I'll watch it tonight.
Okay, thank you, Jason.
So, yeah, it's just I knew that I wasn't going to let him down.
he didn't let me down.
客观地说，它是史上最伟大的单口喜剧特辑之一。我想这就是为什么它会获得，你知道，碰巧它是我的。有时我看着它，我会想，哦天哪，我不敢相信我做到了，因为这实在是太吓人了。今晚真的很搞笑。我今晚要看。好的，谢谢你，杰森。所以，对，我就是知道我不会让他失望的。他也没有让我失望。
He threw his weight.
You don't see that a lot.
He's just, I never thought like a guy buttoned up like that.
He wears a suit, classy, would fuck with somebody like me.
I'm a little grittier and whatever.
And what even am I?
Like, you know.
So, but we kind of had this M&M Dido collab.
他全力支持我。你很少见到这种事。他就是，我从没想过一个穿得那么古板的人。他穿着西装，很有品位，会跟像我这样的人厮混在一起。我稍微有点粗鲁野性，管他呢。而且我到底算什么？就像，你知道的。所以，但我们有点像阿姆（Eminem）和迪朵（Dido）的合作。
Like, it was like the collab that you didn't know you needed.
M&M. Dido.
Who's M&M?
Who's Dido?
We don't know.
But it was like a Batman and Robin.
It worked out.
It was like a great collab.
就像是你不知道自己竟然需要的神仙合作。阿姆。迪朵。谁是阿姆？谁是迪朵？我们不知道。但这就像是蝙蝠侠和罗宾。效果很好。就像是一次伟大的合作。
Are you allowing yourself to dream beyond next year, five years, ten years?
Where would you like to see yourself go?
Nobody dreams bigger than me.
That's great.
So what are some of those dreams, Robbie?
Just everything.
I mean, I'm living part of the dream already, truly, in that I get to, this is realizing,
你允许自己去梦想明年之后、五年后、十年后的事情吗？你希望自己未来能走到哪一步？没人比我更能做梦了。太好了。没人比我更能做梦了。那罗比，你都有哪些梦想呢？就是一切。我的意思是，说实话，我已经活在梦想的一部分中了，因为我能够，这就是实现，
like getting to do this every day.
Like, part of the dream was not waking up to one.
alarm clock.
Right.
And for your podcast, I had to because it's 9 o'clock for a comedian.
It's brutal.
But part of the dream is I don't wake up and dread going to work.
Yeah.
就像每天都能做这件事。梦想的一部分就是不用被一个闹钟叫醒。对。为了你们的播客，我不得不这么做，因为对喜剧演员来说早上9点太残酷了。但梦想的一部分是我醒来时不再对去上班感到恐惧。对。
Like that is over and I never get over that being over.
The day and then the day out of the dream is being achieved.
But it's just, it's keeping everything, whatever I want.
You're developing a show at HBO unentitled, which is great.
You'll be writing it, executive producing it, starring in it.
That's pretty huge and cool and dreamy.
Yeah.
这种日子已经结束了，而且这种结束感我永远都不会习惯。梦想中的日复一日正在成为现实。但这只是，保持一切，无论我想要什么。你正在HBO开发一部未定名的剧集，这太棒了。你将负责编剧、执行制片并主演。这相当巨大、酷炫且充满梦想成真的感觉。对。对。
That's cool.
And tell me one, this is the last question I'll ask you because we've kept you too long.
What's one completely normal thing you just hate doing now that you kind of, you know, are enjoying some success.
Mine is I hate stopping for gas because that's why I got an electric car.
I don't like dishes or laundry, but the biggest thing I hate doing is pumping gas.
Okay.
I like it.
I like to look at people.
这太酷了。告诉我一个，这是我问你的最后一个问题，因为我们耽误你太久了。现在你已经取得了一些成功，有什么完全正常的事情是你现在超级讨厌做，但以前……我的是我讨厌去加油站加油，这就是为什么我买了一辆电动车。我不喜欢洗碗或洗衣服，但我最讨厌做的事就是去加油站泵油。好吧。我挺喜欢的。我喜欢看人。
I'm like a very nosy.
I like to see cars that people have.
Yeah.
I like nice cars.
I love, I go in a window, I look inside.
I'm a very big car person.
Right.
Something I hate doing.
我是一个好奇心很重的人。我喜欢看别人开的汽车。对。我喜欢好车。我喜欢，我走到车窗前，往里面看。我是一个超级车迷。对。有什么是我讨厌做的。
What about you, Will, and Jason?
Oh, no, what's your dream car?
I want to hear.
I'm in my dream car.
It's a 9-11.
Are you really?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm in my dream car.
你呢，威尔和杰森？哦，不，你的梦想之车是什么？我想听听。我正开着我的梦想之车。是一辆911。真的吗？对，对。我正开着我的梦想之车。
I bought it used.
Here's how I did my cars.
My first car was $3,600.
I sold it for $6,000.
I've never bought a depreciating car.
I bought a 19-83 Toyota Carolla, which became collectible after COVID.
It looks like.
the DeLorean.
我是买的二手车。我是这样买车的。我的第一辆车是3600美元。我以6000美元的价格卖掉了它。我从来没买过会贬值的车。我买了一辆1983年的丰田卡罗拉，这车在疫情之后成了收藏品。它看起来像。德罗宁跑车。
It's a Toyota Corolla, but it's 1983.
Look it up.
It's called the liftback.
Yep.
I bought it for 3,600 cash, sold it for $6,000, unheard of.
That $6,000 I bought my first Porsche.
Porsche I always wanted because we grew up poor, but my father always loved Porsche.
And at a certain point, when his whole family fell apart, instead of giving us child support,
这是一辆丰田卡罗拉，但它是1983年的。你们去查查。它叫掀背车。对。我用3600美元现金买的，以6000美元卖掉，闻所未闻。用那6000美元我买了我的第一辆保时捷。我一直想要一辆保时捷，因为我们小时候很穷，但我父亲一直很喜欢保时捷。在某个时候，当他的整个家庭分崩离析时，他没有给我们抚养费，
he scrambled together $5,000, $6,000 to buy himself an old.
It was like a $9-44, one of the...
these weird Porsche models, super cheap he got for like $5,000.
And he sent us a picture in it, like to my mother, like, see what you're giving up?
Wow.
You know what I mean?
And we got that picture.
And I thought he was a dead bee, but I thought it was pretty cool.
而是东拼西凑了5000、6000美元给自己买了一辆旧车。那是一辆9-44，其中一辆……这些奇怪的保时捷车型，超级便宜，他大概花了5000美元买下。他还在车里拍了张照片发给我们，就像发给我妈妈一样，看，你放弃了什么？哇。你知道我的意思吗？我们收到了那张照片。我当时觉得他是个死老头子，但我觉得这挺酷的。
Also, both were true.
And even though I don't have a relationship with my father now, in a way I get to have a
relationship with him in the ways that I'm like him.
Obviously, it's not ideal.
I would love to have a relationship with both my parents.
but I see myself in the room.
I see his eyes in my eyes.
And when I'm in the car, I always think of him.
而且这两点都是真的。尽管我现在和我父亲没有联系，但在某种程度上，我可以通过我身上像他的地方来与他建立某种联系。当然，这并不理想。我本希望跟双亲都能保持联系。但我能在镜子里看到自己。我在自己眼中看到了他的眼睛。当我坐在车里时，我总是会想起他。
This is the car he won.
I get to enjoy kind of a relationship with him.
Again, not ideal, but it's not nothing either.
And it's very, it's not even like I'm a car person generally.
It's just Porsche because that's all I heard about from him.
So I always, so then when I sold that car for $6,000, I got a Cayman,
which I find is abysmal for $3,000.
for $13,000, you know, so minus the six, so $7,000.
这是他赢来的车。我得以享受某种与他的联系。当然，这并不理想，但总比没有强。而且甚至都不是说我本质上是个车迷。纯粹是因为保时捷，因为我从小听他念叨的全是这个。所以总是，后来当我以6000美元卖掉那辆车时，我买了一辆卡宴（Cayman），我觉得这车太糟糕了，花了3000美元。不对，是13000美元，你知道的，减去那6000，所以是7000美元。
And then I sold that one for $18,000.
And I just got into my dream, 2001, 9-11, 9-96, black tan interior thing, California
Cation, exact.
Uh-huh.
And for, it was $28,000 minus the $18,000, $10,000.
And I am in my dream car.
And every day is a dream.
That a girl.
然后我以18000美元的价格把它卖了。我终于得到了我的梦想之车，2001年的911，996型号，黑色配棕褐色内饰，加州车，绝对的。嗯哼。这辆车花了28000美元，减去18000美元，也就是10000美元。我正开着我的梦想之车。每一天都像在做梦。好样的，姑娘。
Wow.
That amazing girl.
That's great.
Jason's had 100 Porsches.
Oh, really?
Oh, my God, Jason, I would love to, if we ever make, I would love to look.
I know, I know, I love it.
One a week.
哇。那个神奇的姑娘。太棒了。杰森买过100辆保时捷。哦，真的吗？哦，天哪，杰森，我真想，如果我们有机会的话，我真想看看。我知道，我知道，我太喜欢了。一周一辆。
One a week, he'd have.
One a week is great.
By one a week and he'd throw it out.
He'd drive it off a cliff.
That's perfect.
Yes, he should.
That's what I want.
You don't you listen to him.
一周一辆，他肯定有。一周一辆太棒了。买一辆，玩一周然后就扔掉。他会把车直接开下悬崖。太完美了。是的，他应该这样。这就是我想要的。你别听他的。
That's what I want for him.
Robbie, thank you for being here.
This has been a dream for us and for me.
I've always wanted to meet you.
I could do another hour.
I know me too.
You're intoxicating, Robbie.
You're unbelievable.
这就是我对他想要的。罗比，谢谢你能来。这不仅对我们，对我来说都是个梦想成真。我一直很想见你。我还能再聊一个小时。我知道我也是。你太迷人了，罗比。你太不可思议了。
We're going to come over.
We're going to blast back and buys next week,
and then we'll do legs and tries the week after that, okay?
I can't wait.
I have felt very annoying on this pod,
just the last is limited.
But it's only because I'm very intimidated by all of you.
I've been able to keep it together.
我们要过来了。我们下周要去疯狂爆练背和二头，然后再下一周我们要练腿和三头，好吗？我等不及了。我觉得我在这期播客里表现得有点烦人，只是最后的……但那完全是因为我对你们所有人都太敬畏了。我已经竭力保持镇定了。
You're incredible.
But I really love all of you guys,
and when I'm chatty and a little bit annoying,
it's just because of that.
You're one of our better guess.
I know, but I love you guys.
I really am such a good.
a fad.
你太不可思议了。但我真的非常喜欢你们所有人，当我变得话唠而且有点烦人的时候，纯粹是因为这个原因。你是我们最好的嘉宾之一。我知道，但我爱你们。我真的超级……狂热。
Robbie, I'm so stoked for your success because you're so legit, funny all the time.
It is exciting.
Watching somebody like you just absolutely skyrocketed is just, it's amazing.
It's fun to watch.
You may see us out in the audience one of these times.
Thank you so much, guys.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah.
罗比，我为你取得的成功感到由衷的高兴，因为你实至名归，一直都这么搞笑。这太让人兴奋了。看着像你这样的人直接腾飞，这太棒了。看着特别过瘾。你们说不定什么时候就会在观众席里看到我们呢。非常感谢你们，伙计们。我真的很感激。对。
I'm watching you tonight.
Okay. Jason, please report back through people.
You don't have to do it personal.
I'm going to send, I'll send notes.
If any of these people can throw me an email.
All right.
Thank you.
All right, honey.
我今晚要看你的演出。好的。杰森，请记得通过大家向我反馈。你不用亲自来。我会发，我会发笔记的。如果这些人里有谁能给我发封电子邮件的话。好的。谢谢。好的，亲爱的。
Thanks, Robbie.
Bye, Robbie.
All the love.
Bye, guys.
God, she's funny, man.
What a talent.
Well, you know, I'd like a couple more stand-ups on this, huh?
Yeah.
谢谢你，罗比。拜拜，罗比。爱你们所有人。拜拜，伙计们。天哪，她太搞笑了，老兄。真是个天才。好吧，你知道的，我还想让更多单口喜剧演员来这儿，对吧？对。
That's a nice guest there.
It's a real nice guest.
Yeah, I can't wait for you to see you, Jason, the special wake-up.
It's really funny.
I feel like, you know, when stand-ups come out of not nowhere, but kind of nowhere, but
kind of nowhere.
People are just discovering who she is now.
With a voice like that, you're like, wait,
真是个好嘉宾啊。这真是个绝佳的嘉宾。对，杰森，我迫不及待想看你的特别节目了。真的很好笑。我觉得，你知道，当单口喜剧演员不是从默默无闻中走出来，而是，差不多是从无名中，又好像不是无名。人们现在才刚刚开始发现她是谁。带着这样的声音，你会想，等等，
Who's that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She is fearless when she talks about all of these topics, you know.
I can't wait.
And we, I think that's, that's, all that sort of humor is sort of gently coming back into society.
And I think that that is not a terrible thing.
I like the way that she just talked, she talked about growing up and saying that in her family is like, if it was funny, then it, that trumped everything.
As long as it's funny and that it's a joke in the service of just a joke, then that's, you know,
那是谁？对，对，对。她在谈论所有这些话题时都无所畏惧，你知道的。我等不及了。而且我们，我觉得那是，那种幽默正在慢慢重返社会。我觉得这不是一件糟糕的事。我喜欢她那种直言不讳的方式，她谈到自己的成长经历时说，在她的家庭里，如果这个梗好笑，那么它就，一切都可以抛到脑后。只要它好笑，而且这个笑话纯粹是为了搞笑服务，那么这就是，你知道的，
That was the thing that mattered in her.
And I love that you, and you can find these,
there's all these specials,
like once a week almost on Netflix, right?
Or these people are getting sort of discovered and launched
and Malini's shooting a lot of those?
Is that what she was saying?
Remember Nikki Glazer too?
这就是她所在乎的事情。我喜欢这一点，而且你可以找到这些，网飞上几乎每周都有这样的特别节目，对吧？或者这些人正在被发掘和推出，木兰尼正在制作很多这样的节目？她是这么说的吗？还记得妮基·格拉瑟（Nikki Glaser）吗？
It just takes one thing and then you're like, phew.
Right. Awesome.
And all the car talk, you know, I love all those car talk.
God, I love it.
I love him.
You can feel him.
It just pulls the car into the fork.
It doesn't matter what you're driving, as long as it gets you there.
只需要一件事，然后你就会觉得，呼。太棒了。还有所有的汽车谈话，你知道的，我太喜欢所有的汽车谈话了。天哪，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢他了。你能感受到他的热情。他把车开进了车行。你开什么车并不重要，只要它能把你带到目的地。
Right.
As long as you're happy driving.
Sure.
You know, that happiness, that's something money can't.
Can't buy.
Bye.
We're for the friend.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisan.
对。只要你开得开心。当然。你知道，那份快乐，那是金钱买不到的。买不到。拜拜。Smartless 100% 有机且纯手工制作。
handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barbico.
Smart.
由迈克尔·格兰特·泰瑞、罗伯·阿尔姆贾夫和贝内特·巴尔比科手工打造。聪明。